more than 1.3 million active-duty
service members are working right now to
keep America safe but how many do we
actually know the CBS News pull out this
morning says more than 90 percent of
Americans have a favorable view of our
military just 55 percent have a close
friend or relative serving we're taking
a look at the gap between troops and the
rest of America and this morning we
welcome Steve Inskeep co-host of NPR's
Morning Edition and up first he met a
family with a tradition of service
stretching back to the Revolutionary War
Steve good morning Nora good morning
while most people don't serve for some
it runs in the family
there's actually a term military brat
which people often call themselves and
they grew up in military families many
of them live apart from the rest of us
often enduring experiences like that of
the Miller family we had three children
serving in very dangerous positions
simultaneously one in Afghanistan two in
Iraq that was the hardest season of
being soldiers mom I'm thinking about
what must have gone through your mind
anytime the phone rang or the doorbell
rang the phone you do dread the calls
that might be ugly the phone rang at
Claire and Jerry Miller's house in 2011
their daughter Caroline lieutenant
Caroline booth was commanding a supply
convoy in Iraq my second to last mission
out there we actually one of my gun
trucks got hit with an ID a roadside
bomb destroyed the truck in front of
hers that was probably the worst one of
the worst moments of my life
was just watching that explosion it was
a few seconds before he could run up
there and see thing thank the Lord
everybody was okay how much of this did
you tell your mom when you had a chance
to call home know that she said mom I
thought I might have lost my guys it was
the worst day of my life this is a
lineup of all of the graduates in our
family from West Point the direct line
from my three greats grandfather down to
my number three daughter Caroline
Caroline's sister Kate also served as
did their husbands their brothers-in-law
their
father Jerry both grandfathers and
ancestors long before them seven
generations seven generations unbroken
line an unbroken commitment forged at
the US Military Academy at West Point in
New York and I think some people are
willing to step up to that that
challenge and I call and others are not
on this campus the sisters learned a
craft that Outsiders don't always
understand the first question is that I
dread getting is have you killed anyone
have you shot anyone or it's just the
wrong question to ask people have asked
most of you as Americans don't know them
many of you don't know anyone who knows
any in one of them last October White
House chief of staff John Kelly called
out the public's isolation from the
troops general Kelly's son was killed in
Afghanistan they are the very best of
these country producers and they
volunteer to protect our country when
there's nothing in our country anymore
it seems to suggest that self service to
the nation is not only appropriate but
required you can't make people
understand what you do Jerry says
Kelly's remarks were necessary you can
only hope that they will become you know
maybe more aware I get a lot of people
who come up to me and in the veterans
day and say you know thank you for
serving and so on and so forth I get
others that don't even know that it's
Veterans Day it's hard to be aware
because civilians may never meet a
military family they move from base to
base as Claire did growing up
when Jerry and I got married that was my
53rd address we had lived in hotel rooms
we had lived in a water tower at one
time she passed on the lifestyle to her
daughter Kate who was moved 17 times in
18 years I've spent every day of my
adult life serving the military either
as a spouse or as a military officer and
many days both why is it important that
people should understand the service of
those who go into the military our top
leaders of our nation
civilians our civilian populace needs to
understand how our military serves who
those folks are what they're willing to
sacrifice because ultimately we will
fall in line and follow our civilian
leadership we the people send them they
face the risks what were the things that
you did to manage that anxiety if that's
the right word well for us you turn to
your faith you turn to it when they're
off doing things that you wouldn't wish
upon them but you know they signed up
for the duty and they agreed and the gym
bless the gym between prayer and the gym
you can get through anything
that's right between prayer and their
gym it's such an important reminder
Steve to us all that Veterans Day is so
much more than the sales or schools
closed and no mail delivery that there
are really people behind it's
recognizing people who served and this
is an extraordinary story because seven
generations at West Point and yet as I
think Nora knows from covering the
Pentagon in the past it's kind of normal
there are lots of families that have
sent generations into the military even
as many other families have no
connection yeah that's my family you
know my sister volunteered and just
returned from deployment in the Army and
it is it's a it's a culture and it's an
idea about service larger than yourself
and to your country and I I have some
empathy for what general Kelly said from
the White House about kind of
understanding those ethos about doing
something that's not always in your own
self-interest you think about that and
we're at the point now where because
we're in the 17th year of war since 9/11
there are people who sent two
generations into war meaning fathers and
sons or more daughters thank you Steve
very nice to have you at the table glad
to be here story thank you great